the pair will be kept away from the rest
of the england players and wider support
team pending further discussions with
phe
the entire squad had lateral flow tests
on monday afternoon
and all were again negative as was the
case with sunday's uefa pre-match
pcr test we will continue to follow all
kovid 19 protocols
and the uefa testing regime while
remaining in close contact
with phe statement ends as a result
mesa mount was obviously due to joining
gary southgate this evening but
unfortunately it wasn't logistically
possible to find a replacement in time
for 6 30 p.m
so we would love to our apologies for
any inconvenience or
caused by that so we'll start now
with questions for gareth and we'll
shortly get underway
with simon peach of the press
association
hi gareth um just wanted to know what
the situation is
from your end will the two players what
will they be
unavailable for you tomorrow uh
well we don't know at the moment simon
um there's obviously got to be
quite a doubt um but there's still a lot
of discussions
and investigations going on behind the
scenes
so um they're they're at the moment
as andy just said they're isolating um
and we just have to find out over the
next sort of 12 hours or so